[Music]
all season long we're celebrating towns
and cities across the country as many as
we can we're bursting with hometown
spirit
eli schmidt and will grimes hometown of
denver colorado is next they even host a
youtube show about it show us around
denver you guys
hey drew i'm will grimes this is my
business partner eli schmidt we are the
mile high property brothers today we're
at cbs4 we're gonna be showing you
everything we love about denver more
importantly what you might not know
about denver but it's work hard play
hard here
what do you love eli guys people in
denver we love to work hard we love to
get after our business but even more so
we love to have fun we freaking love it
here so we're gonna check out what a
typical day for a coloradan might look
like
here we are at washington park in the
heart of denver this park guys is
centered around one of the biggest
focuses that locals have in denver and
that's fitness there is no lack of
things to do here
[Music]
the dairy block is often not known from
even the locals so it is a true secret
spot it is what they call an activated
alley or micro district they've actually
taken what was a normal alley just
between two big buildings and they put
restaurants and shops some interactive
artwork on the weekends you can find
farmers markets you can find bingo
karaoke all sorts of cool stuff out here
we could not let you guys go without
showing you an actual speakeasy
typically we don't tell you the name we
don't tell you where we're at you just
gotta figure that out but today we're
ready life that's right taking this all
the way back to prohibition era which is
huge in denver we are at williams and
graham the speakeasy that is nestled
behind a super secret bookstore come on
you guys i'll meet you by the curtain we
are inside with the owner right now and
while you're fixing these dreams can you
tell us a little bit about
your business on just the history behind
it sure we've been open now for 10 years
this year in 2015 we were naming the top
50 bars in the world very cool
what a pleasure to show you guys
everything denver means to us guys
denver's fit it's active we're
progressive we're about our business but
we're about our food and our fun as well
so if you're thinking about coming out
this way at least paying us a visit make
sure you reach out see you guys next
time
wow denver looks so amazing and i know
you guys have incredible museums i can't
wait to visit will you show me around
too
[Music]
you